[Music]
please consider doing some survival
puzzles with thing yell loud okay let's
do a survival up to 60 let let me just
to do a classic run up to 60 I might put
this up on YouTube so if I decide to put
it up on YouTube Welcome people of
YouTube it's hard to
overexplained like here okay obviously
we have to take the bishop and the first
20 puzzles are generally predicated on
knowledge of very basic chess themes so
I think overe explaining them has the
opposite effect I'm just going to name
the theme and the theme guides you
toward the solution here obviously back
rank mate okay here King is very
confined so we're looking for mate
there's a mate in one here's another
back ranked mate we take the Rooks and
that's mate here's a clear attack
against the king because we've got an
assembly of pieces Queen takes G6 this
is a form of legal mate where the bishop
controls the king's only Escape Square I
again simple Checkmate in two we've got
contact on F7 we go for mate first thing
I see is the battery can we go to G7 no
can we go to h8 Yes again I see the
battery uh that we can build on H2
that's a Checkmate okay A different kind
of battery this time we've got the rook
and the Queen on the seventh we can take
two different Rooks but obviously Queen
F7 Queen G7 was made all right so
starting from problem number 11 things
tend to get a little bit more involved
there's a little more calculation that
you generally have to do so here what I
see is that there's a B2 Pawn it's
hanging and that move results in a fork
but that also walks into a uh
lateral Discovery against the black
queen so white can play Bishop takes H7
check but if you keep calculating you
see that after King takes H7 Queen takes
B2 the Knight can hop into D3 with a
fork against the king and the
queen so this is just a matter of short
calculation short and simple calculation
okay so is promoted we have to take the
queen now it makesense to promote the
most advanced Pawn we need the help of
our King for that this is another simple
Checkmate Bishop takes G2 followed by
Rook takes C1 of course you have to see
that the Rooks are in a standoff so that
helps you see the mate quickly okay
Queen G6 so again I'm noticing a
standoff between two pieces there is a
classic Discovery and then Checkmate to
follow because the bishop is pinned okay
first thing I see is the battery I also
see that the uh Escape Square for the
king is controlled by the bishop so this
is going to be a classic mate you see
this a lot in Puzzle Battle okay so we
have two pawns both of them about to
Queen We simply give our Bishop up for
one of the pawns and promote the other
okay so I'm looking at the king looking
for mating constructions yes Bishop
steps back to F5 that's ma in two
because the queen controls all of the
lateral Escape squares all right this is
a classic mating pattern ma in three you
deliver checks with both of your pawns
and then mate on the side with Rook
H2
all right so here again we're looking
for some sort of a mate Queen controls
one file Rook controls another file so
we involve the third Rook sorry the
second Rook Rook takes B7 again we're
looking for mate and again we see
checkmate with Bishop G5 the king is
helping establish the ma in construction
okay so problem 20 has been reached the
this the second third is going to be
generally slightly longer variations but
still very basic exercises so here for
example obviously we should take the
bishop and now we look for mating
patterns and one mating pattern involves
Bishop C4 King H7 and often times you
have to look for uh retreating moves
right often times the difficulty is
predicated on some sort of move that's
not hard to understand but it can be
hard to locate uh in the SE of
possibilities so particularly we're
paying attention to retreating moves
Bishop C4 and queen H5 okay this is a
classic construction anytime you see a
knight on E5 like this and a queen on
its initial square and then a king on
its initial Square you should should be
thinking about Queen H5 check G6 and
then of course Knight takes G6 and The
Rook is typically going to be hanging in
these okay so the bishop is hanging what
do we take it with well I'm noticing
that The Rook on A5 can potentially be
forked uh with Queen to d8 so obviously
we need to take it with the bishop and
now the Queens are traded we're up a
piece Piggy on the seventh there's
generally going to be a mating
construction we take the pawn how does
the Knight help well we can't go Knight
C3 because that's defended but the
Knight defends the B2 Square which
allows the other Rook to step into a one
with mate you often have these with a
Pawn on A3 or C3 it's essentially the
same
thing okay so I see some alignment of
the king and the queen but obviously
Rook E7 does not work let's consider the
checks Queen C1 check yeah it's probably
Queen C1 check then Queen D2 check and
now a very important tactic that forms
the basis for a lot of the puzzle Rush
tactics where you have the queens in a
standoff they don't necessarily have to
be adjacent they just have to be making
contact and the king is the worst
Defender because when the king is
checked it has to respond to the check
by definition so deflection sacrifices
involving the king are the most common
types of
deflections well the deflection here is
really obvious it's Rook G2 and we win
the queen okay so here again we're
looking for mating pattern some sort of
Arabian mate first it makes sense to
step back with the Knight and here again
your pattern recognition should take
over Rook C8 and Rook d8 is simply
Checkmate okay so we are in check
there's only one reasonable way to
defend against this check and that is to
push the pawn up to C6 now what have
they taken they took a bishop so we are
currently up a rook or up an exchange
but if we take the Knight then they take
on C6 and win all of our pieces so we
just take the bishop and take the Knight
this was just about responding to
threats okay so this one is also going
to be basic mating patterns you're
looking at the age file you're seeing
that the rook and the queen are on the
same file okay Knight F6 and now a
standard Arabian mate with Queen H7 Rook
takes H7 all right so here this is a
question of what pawn do we push the
most tempting move is B7 and it's not
Checkmate black can give the Knight up
for the pawn and it's important to
observe that we are down a minor piece
to start the puzzle that that becomes
important in later puzzles when the
margin's kind of thin out so clearly
it's got to be C7 okay now I'm looking
for some sort of mating pattern against
the king often times this involves
driving the king to the second Rank and
then checking the King again so we're
looking at Queen D1 King G2 Rook D2 King
H3 and now the retreating move that I
mentioned the queen drops back to H5 and
delivers Checkmate why does Rook D1 King
G2 and Rook D2 not work well in that
position the king can slide over to F1
and if we try to ladate him with Queen
D1 the white Rook is going to cover that
from E1 so this is actually going to be
sorry Queen D1 Rook E2 and queen back to
H5 okay this is a simple back ranker
Knight D7 drives the king into the
corner and and now Queen takes SE and
Rook takes SE his mate again we have the
alignment of the queen and the Rook on
the H file which tells me that we have
to break through the H file which tells
me it's Knight takes H5 very easy Okay
so we've got a lot a lot going for us
here the white king seems to be very
very weak let's look for checks and
captures well Bishop takes F3 doesn't
seem very effective Queen E3 check just
trades Queens what about Rook to E3
trying to Fork the queen and the Knight
well the queen has to drop back to D1
but then the queen and the King are
aligned so if we can lure this Rook away
from F1 we'll have a fork and we can do
that by capturing the Knight okay Rook
E3 capture the Knight and then Rook e
one win the queen pretty easy so far
nothing special all right so here we we
probably have to start by recapturing
The Rook I'm not seeing anything against
the white king Knight F3 doesn't make
sense Queen takes H2 obviously it takes
so this is a matter of deciding where to
run and what I'm seeing is that the
black queen is unprotected so we have to
be very careful not to allow some sort
of a discovery my instinct is to run
away from the attack so King F6 but here
we have to do a little bit of
calculation so King F6 or King D6 King
D6 just looks way too scary so King F6
makes more sense because the king seems
to be safer when it runs away from the
attack but that's also where they kind
of get you King D6 I feel like is very
messy they go Rook D7 check King E5
Queen C3 no it's got to be king F6
Queen h8 check and notice that I made
that decision intuitively I did very
little calculation so again King F5 runs
into Rook takes F7 I think we're
actually escaping to H5 and it can be
worthwhile to identify an escape score
before you start here the best escape
square is H5 because if the queen would
have captured on F7 we can actually
block with a minor piece so G4 King
takes G4 and we've successfully escaped
okay this is a simple mate the queen
makes contact with the Rook so if we can
deflect the other Rook it's going to be
Arabian mate Bishop takes F2 deflection
check and mate this is another simple
Checkmate I'm looking at the bishop I'm
looking at the queen they can combine in
a mating pattern we start with a check
now taking with the bishop would make
very little sense here uh because well
the king would just move to F1 and
wherever we would go with the queen we
would give up the bishop so we have to
take with a queen and as always we
return to H4 so look how many positions
are are end essentially with a
retreating move very very common in
Puzzle Battle okay so this is a mating
pattern everybody should know when I see
this bishop on F6 I'm immediately
thinking about a rook appearing on h8
but for a rook to appear on h8 the H
file has to be opened up for the h file
to be opened up we have to give away the
pawn and then get our Rook to h8 so what
do we have here well we've got a
situation where White's King is actually
very safe that's the first thing I see
which tells me that along the the
sequence we might have a quiet move we
might have a on check move and even
though black has a lot of pieces around
White's King I don't actually see a
threat so the most obvious move is Rook
C8 check black is probably going to
trade and try to hide away on H7 but
then we can bring the other Rook to d8
we can set up a battery along the eighth
rink and because black doesn't have any
meaningful checks I don't think that
black will have a good defense to Rook
h8 Checkmate so check takes and here are
the key observation even though the king
is all alone black has no threats
there's no Knight G4
and there's no Queen G3 or queen takes
H3 so that tells me that when I look for
the sequence I'm not necessarily looking
only for checking moves so starting from
problem number 35 or so it becomes
important to also ask does your opponent
have a threat am I in a position where I
can make a quiet move okay so this is a
very important pattern that I've had in
my games before uh what you need to do
is put pressure on the F1 rook and if
you put pressure on The Rook you're
essentially forcing white to get back
rank mated so here's an example from one
of my games that I just remembered where
something very very similar can be
observed okay so this is a game from
2005 and it's very similar it's black to
play and win so you start with a check
on D1 if King H2 then you mate him with
Queen D6 but if white goes Bishop F1
which is what happened in the game what
is the winning move here and I found it
in the game because I was familiar with
the
pattern queen queen E2 Queen E2 but why
not Queen E1 Queen E1 is wrong because
white plays Queen takes C4 and suddenly
uh the queen and the bishop are linked
up so you actually need to play Queen E2
white has a meaningless check but that
doesn't do anything the bishop is going
to be lost and the game is going to be
lost with it okay same concept Queen E2
putting pressure on it doesn't matter if
there's a rook or the bishop there it's
the same idea and then you go for
checkmate all right so we should start
with Rook G7 you could play that move
without thinking and here again this is
pure pattern recognition you need to
realize that dropping The Rook back to
G3 would be mate uh if it weren't for
the move F6 so what you need to do is
you need to take the pawn first go back
to G7 and most people watching this
you've probably come across an exercise
like this okay so here we've done 40 so
far nothing special I see the queen I
see the Knight we would like to go
Knight f so maybe some of your your
intuition is is related to the move Rook
C7 but remember black does not have to
oblige if you go Rook C7 here trying to
deflect the queen black for example can
even take the Knight give up the queen
and black will have two Rooks for the
queen and some pawns uh as a result so
this is where counting material becomes
important Knight G5 uh is a simple
mating construction mate on H7 is
inevitable
41 again we're looking for checkmate
because we've got all these pieces rug
B8 is bad because the Knight blocks so
we got to give the other check and again
we have an Arabian mate Knight B6 and
Rook B7 all right so we're down a minor
piece we're down a minor piece but
White's King is obviously very very weak
So currently our Rook is hanging I don't
see any checks so by default we should
consider Rook moves now do we have any
Rook moves with Tempo well we do we have
the move Rook to A8 the queen has only
one meaningful Escape score Queen C4 and
now I'm seeing the very temp move Rook
to A2 check skewering the white Rook if
the king moves up to D3 you should
notice that Queen takes F3 is already
made if the king steps back to C1 or D1
I'm also seeing that The Rook on H1 is
unprotected so we can slide The Rook up
to A1 with a skewer against the rook and
then we'll be up in exchange and we'll
have a very big attack so Rook eight it
is check check takes okay this is
another mating pattern that all of you
should be familiar with what you should
notice is that the Knight is hanging so
potentially we can play the move H takes
G5 and open up the H file so there's no
logical way to explain this other than
that this is a mating pattern that again
I've had it in my games before and it's
like wearing different clothes here's
the game where I had a very very similar
mating pattern in this position my
opponent went Knight takes E5 Knight
takes E5 and E takes D3 so one component
is that a bishop has to be cutting off
the lateral Escape Square the other
component is that you open up the H file
and deliver mate with a heavy piece so
the mate here is Knight takes G6 very
simple H takes G6 and queen H3 black
gets checkmated here same type of
concept uh where you need to First
remove the pawn from H2 and now you play
H takes G5 with mate okay so here we're
obviously looking for uh some sort of a
mating pattern I I would imagine at the
same time we're noticing that Rook takes
C7 is a pretty nasty threat so we don't
necessarily want to allow it unless
we're we're we're delivering Force mate
so one mating pattern is to go rook d8
and try to go Rook G8 but we're not in
time if we go Rook d8 White's going to
take on C7 with check and then take the
bishop on E7 that gives the king an
escape Square to
F6 which tells me that maybe a more
defensive move should be considered here
can we make a multi-purpose move that
both defends this Pawn but also sets up
threats against the white king well the
move that I'm noticing is Rook to D7
that sets up massive threats against the
white king along the seventh rank it
also protects the C7 Pawn so my instinct
is to play Rook D7 so just looking for a
second do we have any other moves I
don't see anything Rook D7 okay they're
just going to give this up okay G3 the
puzzle continues fortunately we have an
escape Square for The Rook all right so
here first thing I notice is that the H
file is open we have a queen we have a
rook and the move Queen H5 I think isy
pretty
rudimentary okay easy enough all right
so in this position white is going this
way we're playing black and we are going
this way so we do we need to do
everything possible in order to Halt the
progression of White's pawns and it
seems logical for us to try to generate
a past Pawn of our own so the move which
I think we should start with this King
to B2 and this is going to be brute for
us calculation King B2 white plays H7 we
stop the pawn from behind because that's
what we're taught to do king B2 H7 Rook
H1 King G6 white has to defend the pawn
we play King takes A2 white plays King
G7 we play King takes B3 h8 equals Queen
Rook takes h8 King takes h8 C4 G4 C3 G5
C2 G6 C1 Queen and we win because white
has a knight pawn and if the Knight pawn
reaches the seventh rank it's still a
win this is where knowledge of
theoretical end games really helps you
determine the
evaluation okay so they end up going G4
well there's no need for us to move the
Rook yet because White's not threatening
to promote so let's continue with our
plan continue with our plan continue
with our plan and now is the moment
where we need to stop the pawn but we
need to invest a second and say okay do
we stop the pawn this way or do we stop
the pawn this way well probably we stop
the pawn from behind because that's what
we're taught to do now a common mistake
among newer players in such a situation
is to play the move Rook takes H7
remember that you don't you waste a
Tempo by voluntarily giving up the Rook
for the pawn you need to was for white
to promote that buys you a Tempo then
you eliminate that pawn anyway so you go
C3 C2 and we got the same position via a
different move order all right so here
we have a situation where white is down
a minor piece at the same time we have
these two very impressive pawns let's
consider the check so we have Queen F5
check but I don't really see what this
move accomplishes the king can step back
to h8 some of you will probably be
attracted to Queen to f8 check but black
doesn't have to take the queen black can
go King H7 it's very important to notice
that the bishop defends The Rook so
these eighth rank combinations are
likely to fail I'm also noticing that
the queen is making contact with G7 so
the move Bishop to D4 naturally stems
from that observation Bishop D4 Forks
the queen and threatens Checkmate the
queen cannot capture on
H3 because our Queen also protects that
pawn does the Queen have any squares no
black has the Desperado move Bishop
takes two check but I think we can just
take with the King there okay easy easy
exercise we're almost at 50 all right so
here we have a a simple case of using
the two Rooks to Checkmate the black
king this is where just familiarity with
basic mating patterns really comes in
handy the move is Rook D to E4 and that
sets up the Unstoppable threat of Rook 2
E3 mate in a lot of these notice how the
role that is played by the king the king
is in a sort of passive role but it's
participating in the mating mechanism
because it's controlling a lot of the
enemy Kings Escape Square so that's kind
of an important detail to keep in mind
rookie three mate all right one more and
we're at 50 so what is the first thing I
see here well I see that the Queens are
in a standoff so it would be great if we
had some sort of a discovered attack
with the Knight but a dis a discovered
check that is but a discovered check
isn't the only type of tactic here we
have a second order discovered check we
move the Knight onto a square such that
it threatens to deliver a check or
capture a piece with check so you would
you might think oh so it's Knight D4 and
if Queen takes Queen then we first take
the bishop with check notice that the
Knight is now on a defended square and
then we take back with the queen with an
extra minor piece but you have to be
careful where you put the Knight Knight
D4 allows Queen takes D4 and that's no
good we have to put the Knight on E5
here obviously the queen can't take and
now we collect our Loot and we take the
queen and bang we're at 50 okay off we
go to
okay so here what do we have we have two
pieces for The Rook we also have an
x-ray against the F2 Pawn so I think the
move has to be Bishop to G4 because if
the queen slides away then we have
Knight takes C2 if white goes F3 okay
now there's got to be some sort of a
winning tactic so to me there are two
candidate discoveries there's Knight E2
check and there's the much more tempting
Knight takes F3 check I think Knight
takes F3 check is more promising now
Knight D2 check would be promising if
you could then play Knight G3 check like
in that other tactic and open up the H
file and let's say get the queen to H5
efficiently but you can't do that here
the queen has no access uh direct access
I should say to any squares along the H
file which is why I think we should go
Knight takes F3 check and we should
simply go for the gain of material how
do we go for the gain of material where
well we need to step away with a knight
onto a square that carries a threat the
only move that fits the bill is Knight
takes H2 because we're hitting the Rook
we're hitting the queen and we're
simultaneously protecting the bishop
with the Knight which is important
because the other Knight is going to be
pinned bang this is just an exercise in
collecting material okay now we have a
situation where the black king is very
clearly compromised why is it
compromised because it's in the center
and because this diagonal is open the
Knight is also pinned so in a lot of
these the correct solution is Knight
takes E5 and then some sort of a check
but because we're in the 50s you have to
approach each position concretely this
would be wrong because the king can step
forward to E7 and if you give a check
with the other Bishop to G5 that check
can be simply blocked with F6 Queen A4
check looks like it has to be the move
because it makes contact with the bishop
eliminating the blocking moves with the
Knight and if Queen A4 check Queen D7
then we can play Bishop to B5 pinning
the queen forcing the Knight back to C6
and then we collect the bishop on G4
easy
enough okay so Knight F6 this hits the
bishop uh hits the queen hits the bishop
we need to move the queen onto a square
such that it protects the bishop okay
obviously Queen C4 okay so we're down a
rook that tells me the move has to be
some sort of a check there's only one
logical check that's Queen A6 check now
we need to decide between a couple of
different tempting moves the checks here
are Rook H1 and Rook d8 do either of
them do anything well Rook H1 check
white can simply block with Rook G1 I
don't really see the point of that Rook
D check allows the king to escape to C1
so are there any non chicks are there
any threats or captures that could help
heat up the attack well yes there are
there's the move C takes B2 that carries
a huge threat against the rook and if
white goes Rook B1 then notice that the
pawn controls the C1 Square now I think
Rook d8 is going to be absolutely
devastating because the bishop has to
block if it would have blocked on D4 we
would have had Rook takes D4
sorry Rook takes D4 Queen takes D4 and
then Queen F1 Checkmate just simple
calculation there and now we go Rook
takes D2 and again we would have had
eight okay so here obviously we have to
start by taking the queen because we are
in check and black is attacking Our
Queen and black is up in exchange so the
move Queen to E4 makes zero sense it
just trades queens and black is up Mater
so this is this we can play without
calculation now we have to decide what
Rook to capture
and the decision I think is largely
predicated on which move allows our
Knight to escape the easiest well that
clearly seems to be Knight takes d8
because if we play Knight takes f8 that
Knight is not going to be able to escape
from
f8 okay easy enough 54 all right so now
we have a somewhat convoluted situation
we are down an exchange we are down in
exchange but we obviously have this
possibility of Knight takes D3 check so
Knight takes D3 check I think is the
most straightforward move that is the
move that we should start with what
happens after Knight takes D3 check well
if white goes King up to
C2 then we can probably capture The Rook
with check let's put that to the side
now he takes D3 check if the king steps
away to B1 well then we can still take
the Rook on E1 because we are
simultaneously threatening mate on D1 so
white probably has to take back then we
have a check on D3 that looks very
proing so let's look around are there
any other interesting candidate moves
other than Knight takes D3 check well
Queen takes D3 just gives up the bishop
Knight E2 check no we can sack the
bishop on B2 but that doesn't make sense
either so a lot of these you're solving
not necessarily by understanding why the
correct move is correct you're solving
them through process of elimination
Knight takes D3 check only logical move
okay again I think the only logical move
here is to take the Rook with check I
just don't see anything else
that fits the
bill bang and now we just need to find a
calm move so if we move the queen away
you might be attracted to the move Queen
to D4 then we're allowing a very nasty
check on E6 because the bishop is
controlling the Escape squares the
bishop is hanging the pawn is hanging so
I think the move is Bishop F6 we just
control everything defend everything
that's it we're up two pawns and we're
winning in that position 55 all right so
here we're down a piece and again I
would draw your attention to the fact
that black is not actually threatening
any checks so a move like Rook D7 is
very much a possibility here I'm also
seeing a very tempting sacrifice uh with
Rook takes G7 so Rook takes G7 has to be
calculated but so does Rook D7 so let me
start with Rook D7 Rook D7 Rook B1 Rook
takes G7 King h8 Rook H7 that's probably
going to be
winning
Rook
D7 is very
tempting but we have to calculate Rook
takes G7 because if that move works it
leads to Checkmate let's try to puzzle
out Rook takes G7 so Rook G7 King G7
Rook D7 if the king moves back to the
eighth rank black gets checkmated king
h8 queen F6 unfortunately after takes
takes Rook D7 the king can step forward
to G6 and there things get very messy I
don't think that there's Checkmate we
check on F7 but the king keeps running
toward G5 and my intuition says that we
don't have enough there it gets really
messy the king can escape toward E3 no I
vote Rook D7
yep easy enough all right here we there
must be some sort of mating mechanism
and I think there is um if we start with
Bishop H6 check then the king can slide
over to D1 and there Queen F1 is not
mate because we have allowed the queen
to block with Queen E1 but what if we
switch up the move order what if we
start with Queen F1 check and then play
Bishop H6 well that's got to be mating
Bishop H6 three more and then we'll
conclude okay so here we have what do we
have well we have a very exposed King on
G1 and we have a Pawn on D4 and I notice
that that pawn is undefended not only is
it undefended but if we are able to
capture it we will be forking the king
and the Rook so a move that seems
logical also because the Knight is
saying is Queen F7 to C4 because we're
protecting the Knight and we're hitting
the pawn on D4 and we're activating the
queen so Queen C4 we're also threatening
a fork on C3 weirdly
enough Queen C4 let's give it a shot
Rook to
D1 okay so we have moves like Queen E2
but the downside of Queen E2 is that it
lets the white king uh Queen escape the
cage it lets the White Queen travel back
to B3 so I'm noticing that the rook and
the bishop are undefended so perhaps we
should look for a fork like Queen A4 but
again Queen A4 I think is wrong because
white can throw in this check on D5 and
go back to B3 so let me think here for a
second Queen C2 is a move Queen E2 is a
move oh Queen E2 is a move Queen E2
Queen D5 check king h8 queen B3 and then
in that resulting position we have the
move Rook to E3 Queen A4 and Rook takes
A3 deflecting the queen from The Rook so
here things already get kind of
convoluted I would say that most players
with a good tactical Foundation should
be able to get about 53 54 when you get
into the high 50s and into the early 60s
things get very predicated on like pure
calculation and that's when they get
kind of harder to explain and that's
when calculation itself becomes more
important Queen F7 check okay let's do
two more well this one seems very easy I
think ah maybe not well I think the only
logical Square for the King has to be G1
because then we escape all of the checks
but after Queen G1 I think the idea for
black is to play Queen to E6 or queen to
E7 and now we have to be very careful
because this is a mate threat but my
simple question is what if we just play
H3 and create a LT Square for the King
on H2 once the king reaches H2 it's very
important that the queen controls all of
the squares on this diagonal where the
queen could possibly check there we go
that's 59 and let's solve one last one
for 60 okay so we're in check we need to
move out of check well we can rule out
Bishop G5 because it allows Rook takes
F7 check we can probably rule out king
back to f8 because it allows a very
nasty back rank check King F6 looks
completely absurd just a priori so King
H7 seems to be the most reasonable
option on the other hand after King H7
white do Rook takes E7 so wait a second
maybe we need to revisit our assumptions
Queen G5 doesn't make any sense King H7
Rook takes D7 HG King
H3 oh King H7 Rook takes C7 there is a
beautiful tactic and the way that I saw
this tactic is I noticed that the Rook
uh is x-raying the king along the second
ring so if the F Pawn were to disappear
we could actually promote to Queen with
check and so the move here is a move
that removes the guard it removes the F2
Pawn it's Queen takes G3 now if white
takes with the queen then the king is
safe we can just take back and we can
promote D1 equals Queen and there folks
is 60 that's all it took um it wasn't I
mean I really believe that most people
should be able to get 60 with careful
reasoning hopefully you were able to see
that these exercises were not they were
not insane and I'm going to get one
wrong just to show you that starting
from 61 you have to put I would say 3
four minutes of thought uh into each
exercise so there's 60 uh we're going to
pause
here I hope you enjoyed uh these
Solutions and I hope that this uh was
semi educational I went a lot faster
than I did in my previous puzzle uh
puzzle Rush survival run uh for those
watching on YouTube but hopefully I was
able to keep it relatively watchable for
those who find the first 30 exercises
are so to be very
[Music]
basic